what can you tell us about the scale of
anti-war demonstrations in russia
well earlier this week there were
thousands of people who came out onto
the streets all over the country more
than 50 cities across russia uh there
were nearly 2 000 arrests made in one
single evening as people all over this
country are saying not in our name this
is not our war and this is a very
important message that i hope is heard
around the world this is not russia's
war this is not the war by the people of
russia on the people of ukraine this is
yet another military adventure by the
unaccountable unelected authoritarian
and frankly increasingly deranged
dictator in a kremlin by the name of
vladimir putin and it's not just the
thousands of russians who have been
protesting despite the threat and the
very real risk of arrest and and and
everything else that can can happen if
you're opposing the putin regime here
but uh also russia's leading cultures
figures uh writers scientists uh sports
people journalists have been adding
their voices over these past few days uh
to the growing protest here in russia
against uh putin's war
well i was going to ask you who are the
protesters are they
simply students and intellectuals which
we've seen a lot of in the past
no the protesters it is true that they
are mostly young and i think this is a
very important sign because vladimir
putin is going to turn 70 this year and
those russians are coming out to protest
against his regime and against this war
that he's unleashed are mostly young
people and they are the future of russia
and he isn't today is the uh seventh
anniversary of the assassination of
russian opposition leader boris nemtsov
who was gunned down literally in front
of the kremlin walls in moscow
well
you were in fact a close associate of mr
nemtsov and
i guess
this says that there is a price to pay
for protesting
in mr putin's russia you yourself i
think have faced reprisals
well i've been poisoned twice by
operatives of the russian fsb the
federal security service the same
operatives who later poisoned alexander
there were a series of
media investigations led by bellycat at
your london-based media group that has
uh conducted this you know amazing
investigative journalists but actually
uncover the names of the operatives of
putin's fsb
uh that uh you know the go around
killing political opponents of the putin
regime both alexander valani uh and i
were fortunate you know when i was lying
in a coma here in hospital mosque after
the poisoning uh doctors told my wife
that i had about a five percent chance
to survive i cannot
tell you enough how grateful i am to
have made that five percent but you know
boris nemtsov did not even have one
percent chance when that russian
interior ministry officer shot him in
the back on that bridge in front of the
kremlin every year
thousands of people come to that bridge
to chile flowers to to light candles to
pay their respects this year for the
first time uh the authorities here have
made it clear that they will not be
allowing the memorial event uh of course
you know nothing can prohibit and nobody
can prohibit me from going to pay
respects to the memory of my slain
friend so i will of course be going to
the bridge to chile flowers whatever
happens
the west has decided that uh the best
path to changing mr putin's behavior is
to attack his
personal wealth
and standing can you give us
an idea of
basically just how rich is putin and um
where did that money come from
well mr putin has for a long time now
being described by various media
organizations and experts as probably
the richest man in the world and i very
well can believe that because
don't forget the regime that putin
established here in russia is not just
authoritarian but it's also kleptocratic
you know from the classic definition of
kleptocracy ruled by thieves uh and of
course what those people like to do the
people who are in and around the premier
is to steal the money here from our
people in russia and then stash it away
and spend it
in western countries in western banks
western jurisdictions western financial
institutions where that money is
protected by the very same rule of law
that they are denying our own people
here in russia what would happen
if this actually did change his behavior
it is possible that he might be
compelled to realize
that he's miscalculated and that he now
needs to back off
but i think some experts also say
that it is entirely possible that he
might realize he's miscalculated and
simply double down i think trying to
predict what vladimir putin will do is
by this stage more in the realm of
psychoanalysis than political analysis
so it's difficult if not impossible to
say
what is very clear though is that the
international community the free world
the community of democracy should
finally better later never again stand
firm stand in a position of principle
against this man against this criminal
corrupt and authoritarian regime and
what we do know from the history of
russia
is that those so-called small victorious
wars
uh that are uh launched by russian and
soviet rulers for their own domestic
political purposes and to try to divert
domestic attention away from the real
problems that people are facing here at
home
um
those small victorious walls don't have
a very good track record frankly and
very often they actually have
the effect that was the exact opposite
of what was intended i mean just think
back to the crimean war in the 19th
century how that ended for this
aristocracy the russo-japanese war of
the early 20th century and how that
ended for the zarya's autocracy of
course the soviet invasion of
afghanistan in the late 20th century and
what that did to the communist party of
the soviet union so um you know i
mentioned already that this this is not
russia's war this is a personal military
crime a personal military adventure uh
by vladimir putin yet another in the
long list uh but you know what this one
may well prove to be his last
you're right you quote the history but
of course one of the lessons of that
history is that uh
russian leaders seem to try it again and
again crimea
hungary czechoslovakia
chechnya
afghanistan
crimea again and now
ukraine do you think
that
putin
is capable
and willing uh
in any circumstances
to fight this war
uh beyond ukraine and into european
territory perhaps even on nato territory
well you've already heard him actually
threaten the use of nuclear weapons
earlier this week so again this this man
is deranged he could do anything uh but
i think what was also important to say
is that every example you just mentioned
of sort of foreign aggression that
russian or soviet rulers
uh
they were engaged in all those examples
come from uh the times when russia or
the soviet union uh were autocratic uh
domestically you know in those brief
periods of time when russia was a
democracy such as for example in the
early 1990s uh the russian leadership
the russian people stood for example in
solidarity with the baltic states in the
early 90s when uh the soviet leadership
tried to send tanks into lithuania so
there's a really important lesson here
that there is a direct correlation
between the domestic and the foreign
russia between the domestic repression
and the lack of democracy here at home
and the external aggression that the
kremlin engages in there will come a
time there will come a time when
the politics start changing in russia
when the political situation starts
changing because there are millions of
people in russia who fundamentally and
categorically reject everything that the
putin regime stands for who wants who
want russia to become a normal modern
democratic european country uh that it
should be
and you know when that day comes which
none of us can predict because another
lesson from russian history is that uh
major political changes uh in russia can
happen like this you know suddenly and
unexpectedly when that day comes i think
that will be a very good day not just
for us here in russia for obvious
reasons but also for the rest of the
world and for the rest of europe